today the Matt Walsh show another deadly
Tick-Tock Trend once again highlights
the danger that social media poses to
children when are we finally going to
take action to protect kids from the
insanely destructive effects of the
internet and social media also Elon Musk
speaking of social media releases
documentation proving that the hunter
Biden laptop story was suppressed at the
behest of democrat political operatives
plus religious liberty is back on trial
at the Supreme Court the left invents an
insane conspiracy theory to explain a
power outage in North Carolina and our
daily cancellation what exactly is a
dink and why are they being canceled
we'll find out about that today and so
much more on the Matt Walsh show
[Applause]
[Music]
are you struggling to reach your fitness
goals it turns out having a world-class
instructors plus a community of hundreds
of thousands of people who are working
towards the same goal really helps the
guys at Echelon Fitness have it all
worked on Echelon Fitness is the
affordable way to get a workout
equipment a workout community and an
instructor's motivation right in the
comfort and privacy of your own home
Echelon fitness's Connected app provides
thousands of Live And on-demand classes
with great music to keep you moving you
can work out anytime day or night their
full range of affordable workout
equipment includes stationary bike smart
Growers Sleek Fitness screens and an
auto folding treadmill these are all
connected to the echelon fitness app for
The Full Experience Around the Clock
classes including full body workout
programs will keep you coming back one
membership covers a family of five for a
limited time my audience can get a free
bike or rowing machine with a 24 month
membership to get your free bike a
roller Tech's mat to 818181 that's
matt2818181 to claim your free bike or
rowing machine text Matt to
818181 message and data rates may apply
C terms
well needless to say the big social
media story of the week is Elon musk's
release of internal emails and documents
at Twitter proving beyond a shadow of a
doubt that big Tech has been censoring
and suppressing information at the
behest of political campaigns in order
to influence the outcome of Elections
and for other reasons just as nefarious
we'll talk more about all that in a few
minutes there's another social media
story that has caught my attention
though
as well it may not have the same
political implications but it points to
what I think is an even bigger problem
in fact a much bigger problem reading
from the Independent it says the Fatal
Blackout Challenge on Tick Tock has
reportedly been linked to the deaths of
at least 20 children in the past 18
months the popular Challenge on the
social media platform encourages people
to choke themselves with household items
until they become unconscious and then
film the adrenaline rush once they
regain Consciousness at least 15 of
those children who died while filming
the challenge were aged 12 or younger
according to data compiled by Bloomberg
businessweek five of the victims were
aged 13 or 14. the Blackout Challenge is
a modern incarnation of choking dares
that have been around for years but have
been made more accessible to Children
through social media platforms the
choking game quote unquote killed 82
miners when it first appeared in 2008
according to data from the CDC Tick Tock
and its parent company bite dance have
been sued by parents who claimed their
children died as a result of the Fatal
challenge
now Bloomberg goes into more uh detail
about one of the victims and one of
these stories and it is as you might
expect horrific
it begins the five-year-old boys
panicked cries echoed down the hallway
of the Arroyo's three-bedroom clapboard
house in Milwaukee it was February 2021
and he'd been playing with his
nine-year-old sister ariani before
bedtime their mother was at a Bible
study class and their father was in his
basement Workshop out of earshot the boy
had watched Ariana climb atop a toy
chest wrap a metal dog leash around her
neck and hook the Buckle to the Wardrobe
door hinge now she was hanging two feet
from the ground kicking and desperately
scratching at her neck
a few days later after Ariana was buried
wearing a princess dress in Tiara her
nails freshly painted the boy told his
parents what had happened they were
playing a game he said like they saw in
tick tock
that's of course just the latest
dangerous Trend to spread through uh to
spread to kids through social media
platforms like Tick Tock every week it
seems there's another one and it's not
as though as the first article mentions
not as though kids weren't doing
hideously stupid and dangerous things
before the internet existed the Blackout
Challenge itself predates social media
but social media spreads these ideas at
the speed of light not only spreads them
it provides enormous additional
incentive for kids to participate in
them because now they can do it for the
likes and the shares and the views
and also when they're doing these uh
Stupid Reckless things not knowing that
they're stupid and Reckless they're
often going to be isolated by themselves
while they're doing it
and they do it wife again for the hope
the dopamine hit that they get from all
the attention attention that comes in
measurable quantities that they can see
and speaking of measurable quantities
the impact of the internet and social
media on children obviously goes Way
Beyond Reckless and sometimes deadly
challenged Trends on Tick Tock kids
today are more depressed more anxious
they suffer more from mental illness
they're more suicidal than any
generation of children before them in
history they're also fatter less healthy
more isolated they spend less time
outside they spend less time
participating in group activities they
spend less time with sports they have
fewer real life friends they have worse
social skills
and there are many factors contributing
to this but nearly all of the research
and also just basic common sense
points to one thing as by far the
biggest factor and that is their phones
the internet social media
the average kid over the age of 13
spends nearly 10 hours a day staring at
various screens and that's just
recreational screen time it doesn't even
take into account the time spent using
screens for school work or homework
so when all said and done each day
there's barely any time left for
anything that doesn't involve looking at
a glowing rectangle
this is their life
and and we have barely begun to
contemplate and confront the
consequences
of a life lived like this so young
in fact most adults don't seem to be
contemplating it at all according to a
survey a few years ago
and these numbers have probably all
gotten worse as they as that's what the
trends indicate
a few years ago the vast majority of
kids were given their first cell phone
before the age of 13.
and nearly 40 percent have a phone
before they turn 10. and nearly 20
percent have a phone by the age of eight
about 10 of a phone by six
there is even a not insignificant
portion of three-year-olds who are given
smartphones three-year-olds
I mean the best we can say about kids
who are given this kind of technology so
young is that they'll become very good
at using the technology
but that's not saying much as
smartphones are not difficult to use we
don't call them smartphones because you
need to be smart to use them quite the
opposite effect
they can be mastered in about five
minutes even by someone who's never held
one before there's a reason why a
three-year-old can figure out how to use
it
so it's not like you need to get them on
it early so they'll know how to keep up
with a technology-based society
you could never hand your your kid a
phone until they turn 18 and they'll
have it figured out
by lunchtime
and for the sake of getting our kids up
to speed on the latest technology the
cost is that their chance of depression
mental illness suicide obesity isolation
exposure to grotesque and harmful images
like hardcore pornography all of that
skyrockets
they will become overstimulated easily
bored in need of constant distraction
and entertainment
a problem that will then often be solved
by psychotropic medication
they will become Dumber less interesting
people than they otherwise would have
been
but at least they'll be able to type
really quickly with their thumbs now the
message is that they're typing with
their thumbs will be inane and
semi-literate even into adulthood but
they'll learn to say them very fast
they're gonna learn to say really stupid
things quickly that's the benefit
so what's the solution here well an
unlikely person has stepped into that
conversation the actress Kate Winslet
got some attention this past week uh
while promoting her new film which
apparently deals with social media
addiction among children and she called
for uh the government to get involved
let's listen to this
do you think there needs to be more
regulation I mean should we just say
social media shouldn't be available to
people under a certain age or what might
be the answer
it's a difficult one because when you're
an individual in something of a high
profile position you know we do have to
be careful that we're using our voices
wisely hopefully telling stories that
resonate speaking with integrity and and
and leading with the truth those things
are very important to me
I really do struggle with social media
um I struggle with the impact it's
clearly having on teenage mental health
I do wish that our government would
crack down on it I do wish that there
would be certain platforms that were
banned before a certain age I wish that
security checks would be much more
rigorous
um
you know teenagers
where there's a will there's a way so if
they want to get on that platform they
will but I do believe that there needs
to be a lot more protection and
accountability because parents are left
flailing going well thank you so much
government look what just happened to my
child
now later on she says that parents feel
utterly powerless to help their kids
overcome their social media obsession
which is why she says the government has
to step in and uh and she's not wrong I
mean the law cannot solve the problem on
its own but it can at least do something
whereas now it's doing nothing at all
there should be laws Banning Social
Media companies from allowing minors on
their platform that should exist now the
harm that social media does to the
developing minds of children it's clear
enough to anyone willing to look
but we don't need to spend another 15
years sitting around hoping that it will
work itself out in the end
we know all that we need to know right
now to justify taking action drastic
action
how can social media companies prevent
kids from using their services well not
perfectly but they can do more than
they're doing now because again right
now they're doing nothing so anything at
all would be better than the nothing
that they're doing
as it stands Tick Tock welcomes all kids
ages 13 and over
so they're not they're not even trying
to stop 13 year olds because they're
they're welcome 13 13 year olds to use
it
so the age limit by law should be moved
up to 18.
and they should be required to take
steps to ensure however imperfectly that
the age limit is respected this is
possible you know there are websites
like you want to use a gambling website
for example you have to take now there
are ways around that even then but there
are steps that have to be taken to
verify your age
if we were really serious though we
would actually have laws Banning anyone
under the age age of 18 from owning a
smartphone in the first place
um now this idea
only seems over the top and shocking to
people today because we ourselves are
Mindless phone addicted zombies and we
cannot imagine a life apart from our
beloved devices so even the adults when
we hear that well Banning minors we it's
like we can't even conceive of that
because we again cannot conceive of what
what it means to live without this stuff
but there is no god-given constitutional
right to a smartphone especially not for
minors
and we know that smartphones are
addictive and they're harmful on every
conceivable level
so what exactly is the argument for not
Banning their sale to children
like what's the argument for allowing
Apple to smoke to sell iPhones
to kids
no child has ever been harmed by not
having a phone with internet connection
that's never happened
many many millions of children have been
harmed by having it so
what seems Unthinkable to unthinking
Americans Banning smartphones outright
for minors is in fact the obviously
correct course of action
it's obviously the right thing to do
which is why it will never happen
so we're left then with the other
obvious solution although it too is only
a partial solution
and that is for parents to step up and
start taking the issue seriously
um
you know you give your kid a smartphone
because it's the easiest thing to do
because it keeps them quiet keeps them
entertained
because all of his friends have one
because he says that if you don't give
him one he's going to hate you
because you feel powerless to do
anything different as Kate Winslet says
but you're not powerless
I mean you're the parent it's your money
it's your house
you hold all the cards you have all the
power all the Leverage your kid has none
your child will not volunteer to
radically depart from his peers by
living a phone free life
even if it's the life that every kid on
earth lived up until the last couple of
decades it now seems radical and
unthinkable
he's not going to volunteer for that
which is why you can't follow his cues
on this
you have to take the lead
which means taking the phone away
it is a problem if it if it's that that
seems if any of this seems extreme well
the problem is Extreme
again we cannot even fully conceive we
know about so much of the damage but we
cannot fully conceive of what it will be
like
to eventually have a society filled with
people who have been on these devices
and addicted to them practically from
birth
and here's the thing you take the phone
away from me can I guarantee once he's
older he's not going to look back on his
childhood and wish that he'd spent more
time on his phone
no one wishes that
none of us on our Death Beds are going
to look back and say you know what my
one regret is that I didn't spend more
time staring at that damn thing
your kid's not going to regret it you're
not going to regret it for him you're
not gonna look back and say well man I
only wish I just wish I had put him on
the phone earlier
now he will thank you eventually from
saving for saving him from becoming a
fat depressed zombie like all of his
peers
even if he hates you in the meantime
but that's a price worth paying
now let's get to our five headlines
man is it time to stop mindlessly
scrolling if you listen to what I just
said in the the opening there you know
that it is time to finally gain that
higher quality of life you know you're
missing out on if this sounds familiar
then on January 9th join thousands of
men all over the world to embark on a
90-day journey together in search of a
better life it's called Exodus 90. it
was built to help men enjoy the freedom
of becoming who they were truly made to
be Exodus 90 guides you in uh in
removing the attachments that are
holding you back from a better life and
it actually works independent research
shows that Exodus 90 uh the men that
participate report considerable shifts
after the 90 days including stronger
satisfaction rates in their marriages
more meaningful prayer lives and
dramatic decreases in time spent on
their phones for the past seven years
Exodus has helped more than sixty
thousand men build a road map for living
with virtue and a culture that offers
far too many paths to self-destruction
so is it time for your Exodus we start
January February 9th find resources to
prepare for Exodus at exodus90.com Walsh
that's
exodus90.com Walsh
as mentioned the other big social media
stories from daily wire says Twitter CEO
Elon Musk released information through
journalist Matt taibi Friday afternoon
showing that Twitter was working in
conjunction with then Democrat
presidential candidate Joe Biden's team
removing tweets that team Biden wanted
deleted musk said that he decided to
release the information because it was
necessary to restore public trust in the
platform after it censored the New York
Post bombshell report about Hunter
Biden's laptop just weeks before the
2020 presidential election musk quote uh
retweeted Matt taibi's multi-tweet
thread on Twitter writing here we go
taibi began by explaining the company
was slowly forced to add tools for
controlling speech that were designed to
combat the likes of spam and financial
fraudsters slowly over time quoting Off
from tahibi Twitter staff and Executives
began to find more and more uses for
these tools Outsiders began petitioning
the company to manipulate speech as well
first a little then more often than
constantly taibi said by 2020 requests
from connected actors to delete tweets
were a routine one executive would write
to another Mortuary view from the Biden
team the reply would come back handled
timey's post shows that on October 24th
team Biden asked five tweets to be
removed according to Andrew Kerr of the
Washington Free Beacon those tweets were
either drug related photos of Hunter
Biden or pornographic photos of him
which by the way those two things
obviously are not the same like you
could make an argument for deleting
pornographic image I mean I think I'll I
think all the pornographic images should
be banned from from Twitter
um but images of him of him using drugs
they don't have the same argument for
that
you know that's just that's just that's
damaging to him and to Biden for people
to see
but you can't hide behind well this is
this is part of our anti-pornography
policy
which by the way since when did Twitter
even have an anti-pornography policy
um continue celebrities and unknowns
alike could be removed or renewed at the
behest of a political party or reviewed
rather the best of a political party
both parties had access to these tools
for instance in 2020 requests from both
the Trump White House and the Biden
campaign were received and honored
however the system wasn't balanced it
was based on contacts because Twitter
was and is overwhelming staff by people
of one political orientation there were
more channels more ways to complain open
to the left Democrats than the right
um taibi continues Twitter took
extraordinary steps to suppress the
story about the the uh the laptop
removing links and posting warnings that
it may be unsafe they even blocked its
transmission via direct message a tool
hitherto reserved for extreme cases like
child pornography
um
White House spokeswoman uh Kaylee mcaney
was locked out of her account for
tweeting about the story prompting a
furious letter from Trump campaign
staffer Mike Hahn who uh was obviously
Furious about it
um but they they continued of course
Banning people we know about about that
part of the story
and he goes into a lot more detail now
the thing is
um
what what is the overall story here well
the story is nothing important really no
big deal just political Powers using big
Tech as an end run around the first
amendment using censorship to influence
the outcome of an election uh
suppressing information to manipulate
public opinion the other thing we have
to remember here is it wasn't just the
suppression of the story as bad as that
was it was also the lying that went on
okay we heard from people who knew
better that the the this is a this was
Russian misinformation all this kind of
stuff
um hacked materials this we we heard
this from people who knew that wasn't
true
or at a minimum knew that they didn't
know whether that was true or not they
were just assuming or hoping
so no big deal except for the fact that
this is a very big deal
is it a revelation you know as in like
is this new information not exactly
and uh people that wanted to to downplay
this story and and the Twitter files
that were released they took a couple
different attacks and we'll we'll play
some of the cable news
you know uh footage so you can see what
what different strategies they took to
downplay this but one of them was to say
well we knew about all this already this
is all already known
we knew about a lot of it sort of in
Broad strokes but this is confirmation
this is documentation
of what was going on and that matters
you know that's a story that matters a
lot
and what Elon Musk has done here is
extremely important
you know how important it is based on
how little the corporate media is
talking about it
in fact I was uh I was out of the loop
on social media myself over the weekend
because I tried not I you know speaking
of like trying to get a hold of your
social media addictions I tried not to
use it over the weekend because I want
to be with my family and um
and getting back on on Sunday trying to
figure out what I'm you know doing some
show prep uh I wanted to read about read
up on this story and I went and not that
I thought I would see anything honest in
corporate media Outlets but I wanted to
see what they were saying about it and
what I found is that of course they were
saying almost nothing about it like
according to them none of this even
happened
foreign
mostly they tried to ignore ignore it
and when they did talk about it
begrudgingly it's been to sort of
justify their own lack of Interest so
here's how MSNBC handled it with um
contributor Matthew Dowd who uh had gave
his thoughts let's watch that
release these internal Twitter file
files right that were related to this
controversy surrounding a 2020 New York
Post article on Hunter Biden and and
here's what the Washington Post
um says by the time the dust settled
Saturday even some conservatives were
grumbling that it was a dud musk's
Twitter files produce No Smoking Gun
showing the tech giant had been to the
will of Democrats the Twitter threat
based on internal Communications posted
by sub stack writer Matt taibi showed
the company independently decided to
limit the spread of the article without
Democratic politicians the Biden
campaign or FBI exerting control over
the social media Network
this happened I believe it was October
of 2020 when Trump was President right
Biden was in fact at that point running
for office what do you make of what Elon
Musk did right and the dissemination and
distribution now of so much
misinformation what we have become
really Matthew
well uh I mean I think every ever since
Elon Musk took over Twitter we've seen
it devolve into something that is
nothing close to truth and nothing close
to unifying in the country as we see it
today what amazes me is the Elon Musk
might have spent a little more time
reading the First Amendment and what it
said because his immediate thing was
this was a violation from the first
amendment when it's far as I can tell no
government Authority told Twitter not to
do something to me this is and it seems
like they were upset they're upset that
somehow some pornographic or some
revealing pictures of Hunter Biden work
revealed in this which okay
so you get the you get the idea there so
first of all we get this uh we get this
harrowing and horrifying image of what
Twitter has become
it's the Wild Wild West all over again
which which is great to me I mean that
sounds great
um but in actuality if you if you go on
Twitter what you're going to find is
that it's just like very strikingly
normal it's what it's always been you
would never without apart from all of
the Hysteria
from the media about Elon Musk taking
over
if you didn't know about any of that you
had no background knowledge and you used
Twitter you say well this is it's no
different it's like the the user
experience is slightly improved and uh
but for the most part it's like the same
and as far as actual misinformation like
people saying untrue things
that's there's the same volume of that
that there's always been
and it's always been a pretty high
volume
because social media is made up of it's
a social platform it's made up of people
and people say a lot of things that
aren't true
it's actually not the the platform's job
much less is the government's job to uh
police
like and discern truth from falsehood
and tell us what we're allowed to say
based on what they think is true
it's actually not their job
and one of the reasons why it's not the
platform's job it's not the government's
job uh aside from of course the the
obvious Free Speech concerns but the
other reason is that then it's like that
assumes that we can trust them to
discern truth from falsehood and we know
we can't do that
given that as as we know the people that
want to put themselves and have already
put themselves in position of being the
Arbiters of what is true you know these
are the people that would look you
straight in the eye and tell you that uh
men can get pregnant you know men can
have men have menstrual cycles like
these are the people that want to be in
the position of telling you what's true
and what isn't
when they hold beliefs that are
uh
arguably more deranged
than any belief system
held by any other group of people in the
history of the Earth
okay like more drains than flat earthers
that you know you want to go back to
Pagan Cults and they were sacrificing
humans to the Sun God and everything
else
well we know the left they engage in
their own form of human sacrifice
but they're they're their belief system
the modern less belief system is even
more deranged and divorced from reality
than any of that
so they're not in the position to do it
as far as free speech goes you know Dowd
says well this is not this is not to
it's not a First Amendment issue well it
is because again it's political actors
and the government we already we already
know about the reports of the FBI going
to Facebook and the other social media
platforms and telling them hey look out
for misinformation having to do with the
hunter Biden and all that Russian
misinformation
they're doing this
in order to get around
the First Amendment
but it's still an attack on the First
Amendment
it's just uh it's a it's a more
subversive rather than a direct attack
they also brought Republican [ __ ] uh
Michael Steele I think he still would
calls himself a republican anyway and
let's listen to what he has to say for
some reason
what are your thoughts on all of this
tomfoolery over the last 24 hours
I guess with musk is to prove that hey
I'm the right kind of Republican meaning
I'm a trump Republican I'm a uh you know
election denying Republican I don't know
what kind of Republican he is I mean
probably next year he'll be an
independent or democrat depending on how
the wind blows
um but the but the reality of it is uh
putting those things back on the
platform uh it juxtaposition with the
argument that he's all about free speech
um really undermines the central some of
the central tenets of free speech is
that it is it is about yes the freedom
of you to say things but not at the harm
or expense of someone else and so when
you're perpetuating lies and and and so
forth uh you really kind of laughing in
the face of this idea of what the
platform he claims is supposed to be for
the party
um they love it I mean they got they got
the world one of the world's richest men
uh helping them uh ferment the kind of
distrust of the system uh and
disinformation Nation where their
fingerprints don't necessarily have to
be on it like a little plausible
deniability if you will
okay well Elon said
this is who's watching this who's
actually sitting down and watching this
on purpose I mean we know based on the
ratings basically nobody
this is a level of intelligence though
this is the this is the analysis what do
you make of all this tomfoolery
on Twitter
and but I I liked his answer actually I
liked his answer because it was quite
revealing in ways that he didn't intend
and what does he say at the end there
what does Michael Steele say
um he says well this is going to foment
distrust of the system
oh yeah exactly
and this is what is as even if we call
himself a republican still as a member
of the left
uh he is a he is the system he's a
defender of the system he's a member of
the system he's a defender of the system
and so he's going to be opposed to
anything that makes you we're way past
the days of course of Rage Against the
Machine down with the system that's
that's all the people that we're talking
about that became the system and so now
you have to protect the system at all
costs and anything that causes distrust
in the system
is uh is a threat is dangerous dangerous
to them into their uh perceived
Authority and to the control they have
over the population
which is why transparency with their
actual complain this is transparency
it's just letting the the users of the
site see what's going on behind the
scenes
but this is a problem you know somehow
transparency is anti-free speech
stopping government actors from
suppressing speech is anti-free speech
Up Is Down left is Right water is dry
and so on
of course this is what we come to expect
from the corporate media because they
are part
of a conspiracy this is an actual
conspiracy conspiring to suppress
information to suppress speech the
hunter Biden laptop stuff is an actual
conspiracy a far-reaching conspiracy
when you have the corporate media big
Tech uh political
actors the government
conspiring to suppress this story that's
an actual conspiracy in real life
and it is also how the first amendment
is attacked
and will ultimately be destroyed in
modern society
it's not any sort of direct way the
first amendment is destroyed in the end
by mid-level lackeys at tech companies
who list their pronouns in their bio
they're the tyrants who destroy our
Liberty and effectively rig our
elections by rigging the information
that we're able to see
which is why the only remedy here is to
turn the fire hose on and let all the
information out I mean Elon has been
talking about doing this and that's what
he should do release all the Twitter
files all of them
um I you know I'm selfishly I'm
interested also to see my own file over
there which I can imagine is quite
extensive
um I'd like to see the conversations
that they had where they uh decided to
allow death threats against me to remain
on the platform which was a decision
that they clearly very obviously made
um
the ones where they decided that uh that
uh that doxing me is okay as long as I'm
the target uh I'd like to see the the
conversations they had where they
decided that my film what is a woman
isn't allowed to show up in Twitter
Trends I was an actual it was a decision
that they made
and when we first announced that it was
trending like number you know in the top
10 and then it just disappeared just
like that and the blink of an eye never
returned to the trends it was a decision
that was made and of course many higher
profile conservatives have similar
complaints and also you know the lower
profile conservatives have similar
complaints I think we want to see it all
um
that's the only only path forward here
is complete transparent transparency
release it all let us dig through it and
uh and see everything
okay this is from Reuters it says the
U.S Supreme Court on Monday will hear
arguments in a major case pitting LGBT
rights against the claim that the
constitutional right to free speech
exempts artists from anti-discrimination
laws in a dispute involving an
Evangelical Christian web designer who
refuses to provide her services for
same-sex marriages
it's all one sentence by the way from
Reuters uh the justices are set to hear
Denver area business owner Laurie
Smith's appeal seeking an exemption from
a Colorado law that bars discrimination
based on sexual orientation and other
factors lower courts ruled in favor of
Colorado including the denver-based 10th
U.S Circuit Court of Appeals of 2021.
Smith contends that Colorado's
anti-discrimination act violates the
right of artists including web designers
to free speech under the U.S
Constitution's first amendment by
forcing them to express messages through
their work that they oppose
the case course follows the Supreme
Court's narrow 2018 ruling in favor of
Jack Phillips a Christian Denver a
Christian Denver area Baker who refused
on religious grounds to make a wedding
cake for a gay couple uh the court in
that case stopped short of carving out a
free speech exemption to
anti-discrimination laws so in the um in
the masterpiece cake shop decision
really the court just punted on the
whole issue entirely and did so pretty
explicitly and said yeah worse of the
effect of maybe another case will come
along in the future that we'll decide
what they but they came they came down
in favor of Jack Phillips because they
found that the uh so-called Human Rights
Commission in Colorado had had been
targeting him and like bullying and
harassing him to an to a to an
extraordinary extent and so it was kind
of a Smackdown of Colorado's Human
Rights Commission but it was not
an absolute defense of his Free Speech
rights
and now they get a very similar case
where maybe we'll finally get a ruling
on that
um
only this case it's a web designer who
as far as I understand it she was she
proactively was suing again suing this
uh you know the the state government uh
because of this anti so-called
anti-discrimination law that would force
her to for example design a website for
uh for a gay wedding
so rather than waiting around for her to
you know be targeted in that way she's
proactively suing and now it made it its
way all the way to the Supreme Court a
couple points about this that we should
keep in mind
first of all
in all these cases whether it's web
designer uh Matt the the bakery there
have been similar cases with
photographers wedding Caterers it all it
always centers around the gay weddings
and why does it always center around gay
weddings well that's because
nobody
has actually refused service to gay
people Jack Phillips at masterpiece cake
shop that's not what he did
okay it's not like there was a gay
couple that walked in and he said get
out none of your kind are allowed here
it's not what happened in fact Jack
Phillips was willing to sell anything
any any of the cakes that were available
at a store he would assault to them even
if they wanted to use it for a wedding
they could have walked in and said uh we
want to buy this cake we're going to use
it for our for our upcoming nuptials
Jack Phillips would have sold them the
cake
okay he was not refusing service to the
gay couple
what he was refusing to do was to make
them a custom cake for the wedding
specifically because that would be him
participating in this event that he
objects to on religious grounds
now if you just
sell
a cake
you know if you just sell some page
pastries to a gay person or if you're a
photographer and you take a picture of a
gay person or if you're a wedding a web
designer and you design you know just
any kind of website for a gay person
that's not you participating in
something that you find morally
objectionable
that's just you providing providing a
good or a service to someone and the
fact that you disagree with their
lifestyle choices is like irrelevant
um
just as you might object on religious
ground to divorce but if a person is
divorced they walk in they try to buy a
cupcake you're not going to tell them
they're not going to sell you the
cupcake because you're divorced
no it's about the event
I don't want to participate in that
event
and although Jack Phillips may not have
uh refused a divorce person a cake I
could tell if a divorced person came in
and said I'm throwing a divorce party
and I want you to custom make a cake
that says congratulations on your
divorce I want you to make that cake you
would have said no to that too
because that's an event that he doesn't
want to participate in and he has every
right to to do so
that's what the Supreme Court's going to
rule on and you know I think this comes
it's it's a freedom of religion thing it
certainly is
but I think it's even more so a freedom
of association thing
because it it really doesn't
the reasons like
Jack Phillips didn't want to participate
in the gay wedding and his his personal
reason was that it his religion is
because of his religious beliefs okay
but I don't see how the reason even
matters what does it matter what your
reason is
yeah you have religious freedom
but I mean why does he even have to he
shouldn't have to even give a reason I
don't want I am a free person I'm not
your slave I don't want to participate
in this event because I don't like it
why don't you like it
not your business maybe I'll tell you
maybe I won't
but I'm an American damn it you can't
force me to participate in something I
don't want to participate in
and of course the irony is that the the
advocates for gay marriage for so long
have been using freedom of Association
to make their case
and yet they deny it
to everybody else obviously as always
because that's how it goes with the uh
with the alphabet club with the LGBT
activists they are constantly claiming
rights
special rights and even not special
rights that they want to deny to
everybody else and this is another
example of that
so there are really two versions of a
kind of a right answer that the Supreme
Court could come up with here
there's The Limited version which is
what if they if they come and there's
also the wrong answer right that they
could also I I you know I feel pretty
good that they'll have some kind of
mostly correct answer on this case
there's always the option of the wrong
answer but when it comes to the right
answer there's the and I feel pretty
certain that if they have the right
answer it's going to be this which is
the limited version which is that they
they find that people have the right not
to participate in activities that that
those individuals have a religious
objection to so it will be a decision
based around religious liberty and that
would be good that's the right answer
and it would be a big win for religious
liberty
um
these sort of absolutist version of of
an answer
which won't happen but which I would
favor
is that people have the right to refuse
service to anyone for any reason period
now if you're a private business owner
uh you you know you have the right to
pursue service to anybody
just like those signs that we often see
outside of uh outside of of of of many
stores and say we have the right we
reserves right to refuse service to
anyone and of course you see the sign
there but but in reality they actually
don't have that right I think they
should
but the way the laws are set up right
now they don't
but to me it's pretty simple like that's
that's the simplest answer
and it's it's the easiest answer and
it's the answer where where that
maximizes freedom for all involved and
uh that minimizes the chance of you know
corruption and because we're not putting
the government in the position of
getting involved and determining well is
this a sincerely held religious belief
you know is this a we're not getting
they're not in that business
just this is your this is your business
you own it
you're providing a service
you're selling a good whatever it is and
you have the right to decide who you
sell it to that's all
and of course you know whenever you you
say that you hear the um
the dire kind of hypotheticals from
people on the other side who say well if
we allow that the next thing you know
there's going to be restaurants that uh
that'll be just like Jim Crow all over
going to be restaurants that have signs
of that say no blacks allowed and all
that
that's not gonna happen
like there are no cases of any business
anywhere in the country trying to do
that in modern times
if they did try to do that they would be
out of business in about 30 minutes
okay because the protests and boycotts
would be through the roof and there also
be there wouldn't be anyone who would
want to go into a business be seen
walking into a business with a sign like
that
so all that would mean is that they'd
just be you know all of the all of the
supposedly all these store owners and
Shop owners out there who are just like
secret racist and they're waiting for
the opportunity to prevent people from
other races of walking into their store
as soon as they announce themselves
they're all out of business in like less
than a day
um
but I think there would be almost no one
who would actually announce themselves
that way
because that's not that's not
you know that's not actually happening
in modern America
freedom of Association that's the answer
all right
let's see what else do we have before we
get to the comment section I also had
this this is a
so interesting case and you'll
understand why I'm talking about in a
minute but this is from Fox it says a
North Carolina sheriff and power uh
company official said intentional
vandalism at substations has caused
outages for about 40 000 customers
expected to last longer than 24 hours
Moore County Sheriff Ronnie Fields
reported that the mass power outage
across the county is being investigated
as a criminal occurrence according to
the Sheriff's Office Facebook page just
after 7 pm on Saturday several
communities across Moore County began
experiencing power outages as utility
companies began responding to the
different substations evidence was
discovered that indicated that
intentional vandalism had occurred at
multiple sites
so that's the story there was some sort
of intentional vandals potential attack
at a power station and it put 40 000
people out of uh out of you know meant
that they didn't have power
well Andy no now we go over to Andy no
with this report and you see why why I'm
bringing this up
he says without evidence left has spread
a viral conspiracy theory that
right-wing terrorists were behind the
power substation vandalisms in Moore
County North Carolina to to stop a drag
show the sheriff just said at the
presser there is no evidence for that
claim thousands remain without power
trans activist Charlotte Clymer
recklessly spread the unconfirmed claim
to tens of thousands that the vandals in
the power State substation in Moore
County North Carolina was to shut down a
drag show
Sheriff said they've come across no
evidence for this rumor so Charlotte
Clymer said tonight there are
unconfirmed reports in Moore County of
three substations being shot up with
Firearms simultaneously to cut power to
a drag show
and I saw this claim too this claim was
spreading like wildfire on social media
um
and you know if you if you've been
around the block a few times and you see
claims like that you become immediately
suspicious you say where's the evidence
of this and it turns out as we hear from
the Sheriff's Office there's no evidence
of that whatsoever so there was the
power there was a power outage they are
saying that it was something intentional
happened but the left just invented this
story that it was right-wing domestic
terrorists trying to shut down a drag
show by attacking the the power station
like trying to take down the whole power
grid the the local power grid in order
to shut down that doesn't make any sense
if there were you know quote-unquote
right-wing terrorists who wanted to use
force or violence
to shut down an upcoming drag show you'd
think that they would just vandalize the
venue they would just attack the venue
where the thing is going to happen
this would be the most this would be the
most absurd and indirect way of shutting
down a drag show imaginable but it's
just made up by the left and it's spread
all over Twitter and um of course the
truth doesn't matter to these people
and it only goes to show that on the
left they are desperate they are
desperate
for some right wing or somewhere to
attack a drag show
and the more violent the better as far
as they're concerned
if people die as far as they're
concerned all the better
this is what they want they are
desperate for they are hungry they're
eager
which is why they keep inventing these
things
happen that have uh nothing to do with
conservatives or you know anti-groom or
sentiment and they they draw this
connection because this is what they
want and they can barely contain
themselves anymore
and that goes to very bad places
I'll say that
let's get to the comment sections
[Music]
our country might be headed in the wrong
direction but prageru videos could help
save the future of America prageru makes
educational pro-american content that
has been changing people's minds for
over a decade their impact is pivotal in
these times did you know that 70 of
viewers have changed their minds after
watching a prageru video did you know
that 60 of viewers are under the age of
35 well my friends at Prager U are
reaching millions of people with their
educational videos but they have a long
way to go you can help Prager you reach
thousands more by uh by joining Club
five for just five dollars or more per
month go to prageru.com Club five to
join your gift will ensure that prageru
has the support it needs to be here for
the long haul you can join a movement
with thousands of fellow Patriots in the
fight to save America help Prager you
reach thousands more people with
messages of Truth Liberty and American
values so join Club five today and
receive a free prageru bumper sticker
plus an e-book of scripts from prageru's
five minute videos you can join now at
prageru.com Club five today
Angie says hey man I'm so excited to
tell you I just presented a political
poem of mine in my college poetry class
that resulted in a liberal classmate
crying I'm impressed I had this effect
with my poetry now I really need to get
myself a liberal tears Tumblr
um how can you leave a comment like this
Angie and not produce the actual poem I
need to see this poem that brought your
liberal classmates to tears although I
congratulate you on that I think that's
awesome but I got to see the poem yeah
you gotta you gotta show us the poem
um
David says and if you have young
children listening you should turn down
the volume for this question because it
has to do with the big guy s-a-n-t-a
um all right he says Matt I was
disappointed to see your posts on
Twitter advocating for parents to lie to
their kids about Santa lying is lying we
will never lie to our children we don't
have kids yet but it has always felt
dishonest to me to mislead kids in this
way and it will make them distrust you
on more important issues
uh yeah we talked about this I think it
was in the the members block a few days
ago
on okay so on the Santa thing first of
all
because we got to deal this every year
as we get into Christmas time uh first
of all every family is going to do their
own thing right I'm a big believer in
families having their own holiday
traditions I'm a big believer in
cultures having Traditions that we
should protect and cherish and Santa
Claus is a tradition in our culture
which is reason enough I think to
participate in it but families have
their own Traditions too especially
around the holidays and even among the
families that do you know the Santa
thing there are there are many different
variations of what that means
um and and if you decide you're not
going to do it that's fine I don't you
know teach their own that's cool it
doesn't bother me
but if you're going to get all mellow
dramatic about families that do the
Santa thing then I do have a problem
with that especially
um
especially if you don't even have
children so I'm not at all interested in
your Declarations of what you will or
won't do once you have kids if you you
know if you ever have them but here's
the way I look at it
Santa is not a lie
it's not like a deception with malicious
intent
Santa is uh is is exactly the same sort
of thing as unicorns fairies dragons
leprechauns my kids believe in all those
things too and when I talk about
those things with them I don't go out of
my way
to like beat these fantasies out of
their heads right I I play along so when
my three-year-old runs in to the living
room and says Daddy I saw a unicorn I
don't respond no you didn't unicorn
unicorns aren't real you idiot do your
research
have you even googled this
no I say you did wow that's awesome what
color was it
I might I might even call me a a hideous
liar I might even tell her a story about
a time when I saw a unicorn so you see I
enter into this make-believe world with
her and I I participate in that world
I'm not lying I'm participating in the
fun in the Make-Believe and Santa is the
same kind of thing Jordan Peterson uh
has talked about this and I like the way
you put it says that Santa is a game
okay it's not lie it's a game it's like
a play it's a uh it's a story
that you're
uh you know telling to your kids and a
game that you're playing with them
do they understand that the game isn't
100 real well no but they also don't
understand about any game you play with
them at a certain age
you know and that's all it is
and it's a it's a it's a great way for
them to use their imaginations and I
also just think like kids have
an opportunity when they are kids when
they're young kids
to to live in this
you know magical world where where there
are dragons and there are unicorns and
there are leprechauns and there are you
know all these Fantastical things going
around and there is and there is a fat
guy you know flying through the air at
light speed with his reindeer like they
have they have an opportunity to live in
that world and to really live in it at
least in their own minds
um and it's and it's totally healthy and
it's completely normal okay it's not
like we're fostering unhealthy
self-destructive delusions this is
normal and healthy for them at their age
and they have that opportunity and it's
a wonderful magical thing and I I don't
understand trying to take it from them
I don't get it
all right Chris X says speaking of
magical wonderful things I hope Matt
will post a picture of the walrus once
it arrives
I I absolutely will and I did the walrus
was delivered as promised on Friday and
I can't tell you what a delight it has
been my kids love the walrus right I
mean they really do they absolutely love
and they spent the whole weekend playing
with the walrus and I love them too
here's a picture that my wife took
and it's just to show you how excited I
am about the walrus I never ask her to
take pictures I think I don't think in
my life I ever have asked her to take
one this is the first time in our
marriage when I've ever said you got to
get a picture of this those words have
never crossed from my lips except for
here because we needed to get the
picture I needed a picture with my
cherished walrus and you can see there
you see how big it is
um it takes up like this whole corner of
our of our living room and um one of the
most joyful moments of my life for me
and the kids not so much for my wife
uh but the the great thing is that she
threatens to throw it away
but she literally can't because the
thing weighs like a hundred pounds and
it's way too big so what she says I'm
gonna throw that thing away oh yeah how
are you gonna do that you can't even
lift it so it's there
besides like I said he's the kid's best
friend so on Saturday I walked into the
living room and I found my six-year-old
um curled up on the on the walrus with a
blanket sleeping because I didn't put
him up to this he's just like you wanted
to take a nap
which is amazing enough on its own by
the way he just wanted to take a nap I
don't know and uh and he's curled up on
the wall or sleeping there
isn't that adorable and I showed my wife
I took that picture I showed my wife and
I know she thinks it's the cutest thing
ever but she can't fully admit it so
she's trying to suppress
how cute it is
the most I could get her to admit she
said this last night she said that the
walrus because my we I was putting we're
putting the kids down for bed and my
three-year-old was hysterical crying
because she didn't she didn't she wanted
to be with the walrus she was playing
with the walrus and she didn't want to
go to bed
and uh and she was saying no no I want
to play with Johnny you know Johnny
Walkers and so my my wife the most I get
to admit she said that it's a blessing
and a curse having the walrus
and I said so you're saying it's a
blessing
see I told you
well it's hard to believe but the
holidays are already here now I know a
lot of you are already daily wire Plus
members and get to enjoy the great
content that we have released this year
like Tara on the Prairie the greatest
lie ever sold in my very own documentary
what is a woman for those of you who
haven't been able to enjoy it because
you're not a member now is time to take
advantage of our 30 holiday sale this
also applies to a gift membership so
don't miss this opportunity to get
everyone on your list an annual gift
membership from daily wire plus with
code holiday at checkout since joining
daily wire plus Jordan Peterson has been
on fire with a ton of great content
Jordan went with our production team to
Washington DC filmed a fantastic
documentary on the Museum of the Bible
called logos and literacy in it Jordan
meets with historians theologians and
philosophers to discuss the history of
the Bible and its influence on the world
it's as beautiful as it is engaging
Jordan even sent us a note to say how
happy he was with the way it turned out
uh he actually watched it twice so
remember this content is only available
for daily wire Plus members so sign up
today use code holiday at checkout to
get 30 off your new annual daily wire
Plus members deliwire.com Walsh that's
delaware.com Walsh today now let's get
to our daily cancellation
[Music]
well good news everyone there's a new
acronym in town and it's the trendiest
one on the market right now the website
pop sugar where I go for all the most
important news has the story about those
living the d-i-n-k lifestyle dink
so it says quote in the United States a
growing number of couples live a dink
lifestyle instead of the historically
traditional family structure that
includes having children at least
according to data the dink lifestyle AKA
dual income no kids is generally used to
describe a family where neither adult in
the partnership has children and both
are working paying jobs according to the
latest data from the U.S uh Census
Bureau the number of adults living
without children has increased by 19
since 1967. in addition a 2021 Pew
Research Center survey found 44 of
non-parents between the ages of 18 and
49 say it's unlikely they will have
children the figure is up from 37 in
2018 indicating a growing trend of
couples delaying having kids or
foregoing them all together
several factors that contribute to the
rise of the uh dink lifestyle including
a delay in median age at the time of
marriage financial reasons and shifts in
life goals
now apparently dink isn't technically
new the acronym was coined I guess in
the 80s from what I understand but has
become more popular recently and it's
only further proof proof of the age-old
saying that I just made up which is this
just because you can make something into
an acronym doesn't mean you should
dink sounds like some kind of slur you
know it's like not a label that people
willingly apply to themselves yet still
I must admit that the name seems to fit
the people who have embraced it
this is one dumb trendy acronym that I
will happily use use if you want to be
called a dink I will call you a dink
in fact from my brief research online I
discovered that there are subsets within
the dink Community for instance there
are I'm not making this up
there are people who apparently call
themselves dink wads
dual income no kids with a dog denkwad
once again I concede that dink wad okay
the the dink wads have chosen a name
which fits them perfectly
childless people with with dogs pink
wads
so what you want to identify yourself as
I will happily call you that
and I will encourage others to do the
same
so going back to the article we're given
more specific information about these
dinks and Dink wads it says quote like
any partnership in family structure the
dink lifestyle isn't a one-size-fits-all
term instead couples come to live the
dink lifestyle for various reasons Jay
zigmont Ph.D and founder of child free
wealth in Water Valley Mississippi tells
pop sugar for sigmat and his wife the
dink lifestyle provided more flexibility
in creating a life that works best for
them which he's also seen with many of
his clients sigmon says that his in his
experience those who choose to live a
dink lifestyle do so for three main
reasons they never wanted children
they're Finance they are focused on
financial wellness and they desire
freedom
there's another recent article this uh
this one on Yahoo and written by a dink
and it goes into more detail about the
reasons why the dinks decide to be such
dinks it says quote we've all seen the
means and even the bumper stickers
colorful displays proclaiming I am a
Funko or celebrating being Mom to fur
babies only there are countless ways
some share that they're enthusiastically
certain they're living their best life
thanks to being Child free and once and
once these happy Souls of which I am one
find a partner there's another term that
comes into play dink I'm a proud dink my
husband and I are both in our late 30s
and have chosen the dink life and no we
aren't those married to our career types
while we both enjoy success in our
fields we enjoy a deep bond that I can't
imagine would be possible if I had to
give so much of myself to caring for a
child we are not selfish individuals but
instead selfish with the time we have
together for the sake of our
relationship
we're then given other examples from the
dink Community to show that there are
many and varied reasons why a dink might
choose to be a dank it says
in recent times I've discovered that
we're not alone in addition to Circles
of friends that share this similar
mindset there's an entire online
community dedicated to removing the
pressures and stigmatism surrounding the
subject danaya casalis a 33 year old
microbiologist an online fitness coach
resides in Florida with her partner
together they've created a space and a
safe and inspiring space on Instagram
for others like them to share the daily
humorous and often reluctant encounters
they face as dinks quote I knew in my
early 20s that I for sure had no desire
to have kids casellas tells Yahoo life I
don't get excited over babies but I'm
good with kids I have a silly
personality and enjoy being around them
but taking on the huge responsibility of
raising someone just doesn't appeal to
me I was told I was crazy selfish and
that I would regret it I'm now 33 Child
free and living my best life
the best life she speaks of Casella
spent years living in New York City on a
journey of self-discovery and she and
her partner now enjoy the spontaneity
that dink life brings like making last
minute dinner plans playing in soccer
leagues and taking trips to Universal
Studios Orlando
now every example in the article is like
this it turns out that there are not
actually many in varied reasons why
people become dinks all the reasons are
basically the same they want more money
they want more time to go on vacation
and they want fewer responsibilities
and that basically sums it up
it is rather revealing that even in
these propaganda pieces and I've read a
lot of them designed to promote the
child-free life rarely do you hear about
someone who uses their quote freedom to
go on great Heroic Adventures you know
nor do you hear about them devoting
their free time to serving their
communities nor any other worthy Pursuit
instead they just buy more stuff and
they take sad little childless trips to
theme parks and they eat at restaurants
more often
so they dedicate themselves to being
more active and more loyal consumers in
other words
that's what it always comes down to
they choose to not have kids so that
they can consume more and become more
devoted consumers
for all the high-minded theoretical talk
about what a child-free quote-unquote
life could free a person up to do
this is what they actually do this is
what it actually means they're not
trudging through unexplored parts of the
Amazon or inventing a cure for cancer or
building homes for poor villagers in
Namibia or whatever they are rather far
more focused on entertaining themselves
and their Adventures of exploration will
generally be relegated to tourist spots
that have already been explored by
approximately 900 million people before
them that's the reality
and this is the problem
with the dink life one of the problems
anyway
and we must as always stipulate though
it should be clear by now that we're
talking about couples who choose not to
have children okay not those who want to
but are unable
the issue is the lifestyle choice
and the first way you can tell that a
lifestyle choice is problematic is by
extending its logic as far as it will go
so the dinks say that dink life is good
and Noble and it's wonderful and and and
you know and and all that something to
be proud of
yet if everyone chose to be Dinks human
civilization would quickly collapse and
in less than a century our species will
go extinct
so if everyone chose to be dinks like
today
within 20 years there is no civilization
anymore it's it collapses it's so
top-heavy that it would just fall over
on itself and you know a few more
decades it's extinct
so if your lifestyle Choice can only be
adopted by a relatively small percentage
of the most privileged members of the
human race or else civilizational
catastrophe would ensue that's a pretty
good indication that there's something
wrong with your lifestyle choice
okay and that and that applies across
the board
if your lifestyle choice
cannot be adopted by very many people or
else it will destroy the the human race
then there's probably something wrong
at the very least it proves beyond a
shadow of a doubt that your lifestyle is
not one we should recommend
because again if too many people took us
up on the recommendation the human race
disappears
so there are those who are doing the
work to ensure that our race survives
and thrives and there are those more
interested in taking trips to Universal
Studios those two choices are not equal
by any objective measure
but the truth is that the dink approach
does plenty of damage even before it can
get to the point of causing a mass
extinction event
the point is that when we encourage
people to get married and have children
we are encouraging them to look towards
the future
and to live lives of love and service
not every parent is going to you know
live up to this calling of course you
could be a parent and still be a selfish
uh SOB that's for sure but at least as a
culture we are pointing people in the
right direction
the other option is to point people
towards lives centered around themselves
their own Comfort luxury entertainment
that's no way to build or maintain a
thriving Society
and on an individual level it's a recipe
for a life that while comfortable
is ultimately empty and purposeless
purposeless
you know the consequence of being
sentient self-aware relatively
intelligent creatures is that is that we
cannot help but search for meaning
no other creature as far as we know on
Earth is bothered by this detail
so great white sharks aren't reflecting
on the meaning of it all as they hunt
and devour a seal ants aren't wondering
what it all means as they swarm over a
melting popsicle left in the pavement
only we are left with these questions
and we cannot Escape them
and what we find ultimately is that
momentary pleasures and Amusements
cannot satisfy our need and longing for
meaning
they can only distract us from them but
not forever
not for long
family life gives us purpose and meaning
and even that is an ultimate meeting in
and of itself our ultimate meaning our
ultimate purpose is to know God love him
and serve him but family life points Us
in that direction towards the Eternal
and the transcendental it grounds Us in
something that goes beyond transcends
self-service and self-satisfaction
and the cost of that
is that we can't take as many vacations
but that is a price well worth paying
and it's why today I must say
both the dinks and the denquads are
canceled that'll do it for this portion
of the shows move over to the members
block hope to see you there if not talk
to you tomorrow Godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]